anyway a math professor at Brooklyn
College claims that merit-based
education meeting rewards linked to hard
work and talent is a tool of evil
whiteness in an article Laurie ruble
says colorblindness also holds back
minorities because it doesn't admit that
racial strife still exists according to
campus reform the teacher recommends
injecting social justice issues into
actual math lessons so I came up with an
example see sally is carrying six ski
masks to an auntie for Ally she
encounters four evil white males who
steal two of them
how many ski masks does she have left
answer you're racist but even social
justice might not be enough here
enlighten teachers may still think
effort leads to reward which again is
very evil anyway such conclusions turn a
real problem into a bigger one to deem
achievement based reward as racist
suggests that certain students can't
handle actual effort and that becomes
part of their identity the kid who can't
do what other kids can I don't know i
don't think color blindness or
merit-based reward holds back students
it's teachers who seek to reduce
education to mere identity politic
algebra this is no help for students
once they hit the real world where
results matter especially if you're
looking for a raise facts have no
feelings and the more you focus on
identity the less you focus on other
things that really matter more that math
is so simple even I can do it and I
majored in sleep Dana
meritocracy is racist math is math like
raging the word problems helps a kid
figure out the answer to the fact
problem I think what the fact is I don't
no problem with that
really hmm Jessie thoughts my thought is
the opposite of meritocracy racist
how does she grade her papers does she
say oh the Asian kid I'm gonna give him
this grade but the black kid it's gonna
be another great but the Latino kid
you're not allowed to do that I think
that's almost I don't know if it's
illegal but it's totally racist and in
sports meritocracy works in sports look
at the NBA it's mostly black it's
because the blacks are the best play
they're just the best scores they're the
best offenders or business people in
Wall Street they don't care what color
you are as long as you make money for
them they'll hire anybody except for
sure except for true not true short
people are often discriminated against
on their studies studies show that tall
people often get higher salaries and get
shot I could get jobs faster than short
people I should be I think all the
presidents are very tall white men
except for Obama and he's tall black guy
wait wait Oprah's next one I think your
concept of meritocracy though differs
from my because I think what the
suggestion is is that people aren't
trying hard enough or don't have the
ability to succeed and of course merit
in our country especially in the
education realm comes you know a CTS
SATs initially it was to provide an
additional screen to keep newcomers out
of the elites in this society but I will
see what the SAT was commercial yes but
but here's the thing I think that
compared that the impact you know the
impact of this is so it's enough to make
you crazy because you hear from black
kids
oh it's acting white if you are a very
aggressive village real student and it
makes me nuts
yeah but at the same time then you don't
want people to making the assumption
that well this kids having trouble and
maybe the kids having some difficulties
at home or at school or whatever and
can't do it you want both sides that I
think repeat what President Bush said
which is that would be the bigotry of
low expectations and that we shouldn't
leave any children behind what MIT would
say you Kimberly have a child I do and
he's actually quite good at math I find
math hard that's why I don't do word
problems well hey math is just hard I
was outstanding all the way up to
algebra that was fabulous all part yeah
decent characters and then forget the
rest of it you know girl women they
oftentimes discriminate against women in
math well it's fine it worked out
fantastic I'm not gonna complain about
it
so God sometimes you're better at
certain things than others but I hear
what Danis saying you want to like make
it so that people can understand the
whole point is to learn and to make it
and put it in a way that is easy to
understand it maybe people are dyslexic
or of learning differences and the word
problems are harder that way I totally
get it
I mean but I'm not trying to go back and
retake the SAT it just saying no way but
you want to have uniform standards for
everybody or else you judge let's be
honest the plane and real quickly and my
math on Trump support so when math was
bad on Tom Arnold I'm maybe just a fan
of mine but it's not a president Trump
getting confused Tim Allen who's not
sitcom dad's all kind of blend together
that what it is yeah it is it's like I
can't I get very confused on who exactly
my god member that married with children
but my favorite show somehow I'm not
surprised that was the beginning living
room of waters world Trump it was the
opposite of uplifting but it was funny